all right also tonight A hotly
anticipated phone call in Washington D.C
today as the house oversight committee
chairman James Comer and FBI director
Christopher Wray along with Senator
Charles Grassley spoke about the
possible release of a document that
claims that Joe Biden accepted a 5
million dollar bribe from a foreign
National when he was vice president and
took specific actions in exchange for
that now Comer has subpoenaed that
document the FBI has not yet turned it
over the Bureau says that Ray offered
chairman Comer the opportunity to review
the document in a secure setting Comer
says that offer is not good enough he
now plans to move forward with his
effort to hold director Ray in contempt
of congress now the FBI also claims that
just because the Biden bribery
allegation is on paper does not mean it
is true but apparently the bureau has a
track record of downplaying negative
information especially about anybody
with the last name Biden we also have
FBI whistleblowers telling CBS news that
the agency was actively labeling
evidence against Hunter Biden as you
guessed it disinformation even as even
if it was completely verified it was
reaction to all of this as house
oversight committee chairman James Comer
first your reaction to the um
to the vote tonight on the spending Bill
Congressman what's your reaction
well I think your two female guests did
a great job explaining that this was a
pretty good deal look the there are
Democrats mad because we cut spending
too much there are some Republicans mad
because we didn't cut spending enough
that's called governing I don't like it
but when we're one-third of the equation
the house is one-third the Senate's a
third and the White House is the third I
think it's about as good a deal as we
could have gotten so I'm glad that we've
moved past this and now we can focus on
trying to get spending under control
again in October when the full year
budget appropriation comes due again all
right let's talk about your call earlier
today with the FBI director Christopher
Ray along with Senator Chuck Grassley
and you have been asking and demanding
that they turn over this 1023 form uh
director Ray acknowledged that they have
it he would produce it for you in
private
um let me ask you about this because my
understanding of a 1023 is is pretty
simple is that it is a allegation you
and Senator Grassley believe it's a
credible allegation based on the
individual whistleblower that brought it
to your attention Okay I tend to trust
you too uh however the question I have
is are we going to start releasing all
10 23s publicly would that result in an
invasion of privacy or the potential of
making accusations against people that
they have not fully corroborated and why
not take advantage of the FBI director's
offer to see it in like a private skiff
or whatever you know whatever area he
deemed secure
well to answer that question Sean he's
he offered us the opportunity to come
look at it in a private ship but he was
going to redact it my experience with
getting documents from the FBI when
they're redacted they're very it's all
black lives they don't show anything but
I'm going to say on this show what we
told director Ray what Senator Grassley
told director Ray he and I and I had
already seen
the 1023 form we knew what was in the
1023 form until we told director Ray
that he never even admitted that the
form existed
so the the level of confidence that we
have with director a only went down it
only declined throughout the
conversation so we will go there and
look at the redacted document but we
know what's in the document and the
reason we find this allegation credible
not only because of the credibility of
The Whistleblower but because we've seen
a pattern of Joe Biden when he was vice
president leaving a country after he
talks about foreign aid and foreign
policy and his family members start
receiving payments from that company
through shell companies that are then
laundered down to Biden family members
so there is a pattern of behavior
and we saw that in Romania we've seen
that in China we've seen that in other
countries that would suggest that this
allegation has Merit well by the way
with all the Press reports I've been
reading today about your phone call not
one of them actually mentioned that
minor little detail that it would be
redacted uh he left that part out which
is a big deal that's a huge deal that's
not transparency all right so that means
now that you will move forward with
contempt charges against the FBI
director tell us what that will look
like because you know let's say he comes
in I I would doubt that he's he may just
not show up or uh if he just would with
the FBI director plead the fifth uh on
on an issue and doesn't Congress
especially your committee above all
others have oversight that that is your
job to have oversight it's our job
that's what this committee does that's
what this committee was created to do we
have oversight over the federal
government but for some reason the FI
yeah thinks they're immune to oversight
look the Durham report proved that the
FBI has lots of issues we brought that
up Senator Grassley and I reminded
director Ray that the Durham report was
devastating to The credibility of the
FBI and his response was that that all
happened before he became FBI director
so look all we want is this for
and it's not classified they can redact
the name of the informant I'm fine with
that I would have redacted it if I had
the document you know without that
reduction let's protect the human
informant I agree with that we should
always protect the humanity I want to be
very clear you believe in The
credibility of this this whistleblower
you believe that the allegation that Joe
Biden as vice president uh received
money for his family or family
Enterprise in exchange for specific acts
that he took as the vice president of
our country you believe that that is a
credible charge and allegation made by a
credible witness law
it's so hard to believe Sean I wouldn't
have believed it had I not seen the bank
records have I not seen the shell
companies that the Biden family created
to launder money that was being received
from foreign Nationals after Joe Biden
left the country with foreign aid checks
so if there's a pattern here that would
suggest this is a credible allegation
now I went through this at treasury just
a few months ago they said oh you don't
need access to these suspicious activity
reports these Bank violations at the
Biden have you're never going to find
anything there that's what Janet Ellen
kept saying we finally got in there and
guess what we found Sean we found that
Joe Biden lied when he said his family
never took money from China we found
that Joe Biden actually did and his
family did receive payments while he was
vice president and we found five new
Biden family five new providing family
members that were in on the input
peddling team so that was a very
productive trip to the treasury cabinet
even though they said we wouldn't find
anything I think we'll find this same
sort of evidence with the FBI documents
and and directory to be clear will now
face contempt of congress unless he
produces this document like we asked
this unclassified document all right
Tuesday or Wednesday whenever we have
the markup all right James culmer
Congressman thank you we appreciate it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else